surkiffe pokémon non franchement sur
tous les sens sera lente et un premier
j'adore et franchement je trouve que il
ya un truc un peu comme des animaux
placés ce que je me disais au début
sauf que finalement de moins en moins
soit parce que les combats d'animaux
c'est pas très légal et puis on mange
pas un pokémon est un animal on lui
donne une vraie identité en lui donnant
que les pokémons ballot renoncer le nom
de leur espèce finalement puis quelque
chose c'est pikachu en même temps c'est
tout les pikachu attend mais du coup si
les pokémon ils ont un statut inférieur
aux animaux ils sont quoi alors
du coup par rapport aux combats entre
les pokémon éolien qu'on a avec les
pokémon
on pourrait dire que les pokémons ils
ont un statut inférieur aux animaux
notamment parce qu'en plus ils sont
utilisés pour faire des tâches par
exemple générer l'électricité vous ai
pas menti
et puis sont aussi utilisés pour faire
des démos nathan par exemple où creuser
des tunnels en fait les pokémon sont
exploitées par l'homme
mcd et serait en fait nan franchement
dirais trop des esclaves on dirait parce
qu'ils sont faits pour ça non parce que
quand on a des petites tortues qui
crachent de l'eau qui sont prêtes à être
pompier à quel moment on peut refuser en
fait en tout cas je pense que c'est ce
qu'aurait dit aristote
parce que pour lui les esclaves étaient
faits pour être esclaves ils étaient
esclaves par nature mais c'était même
mieux pour eux qu'ils à 1 m c'est ce
qu'il dit dans la politique et c'est un
peu comme pour certains pokémons
finalement je pense notamment aux
pokémon qui ont besoin de l'affection de
leurs dresseurs et de bonheur pour
évoluer
pour continuer sur aristote et si on
modernise un peu il dit que bah si les
machines pouvaient marcher tout seul on
n'aurait pas besoin d'esclaves
alors lui le dire en mode ça arrivera
jamais et cédera donc on aura toujours
besoin d'esclaves
en fait il le dit pour prouver la
nécessité d esclaves
sauf que l'histoire lui a donné tort et
raison à la fois déjà que
l'industrialisation
on a eu ces machines qui marchait tout
seul mais ensuite l'esclavagé a été
aboli aussi et parce que justement cette
industrialisation l'a rendu
économiquement utile donc en fait il a
eu tort parce que non les esclaves sont
pas nécessaires mais là une raison parce
que sa connexion logique s'est vérifié
c'est exactement ce que dit le
matérialisme historique de marx en raw
pour lui les forces productrices donc
l'état des techniques à un moment donné
de l'histoire sont fraîchement lié aux
forces de production c'est à dire les
classes sociales qu'elle détermine aussi
bon on est partis super loin mais le
truc c'est que quand tu regardes pokémon
tu penses pas à l'asservissement
parce qu'en fait les pokémon globalement
ils ont l'air de kiffer or un esclave
qui quitte son environnement
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt de la
domestication alors je te parle d'un
point de vue philosophique
parce que oui un esclave même si qui
fait esclave sur le papier ça c'est un
esclave mais à voir sa volonté et sa
condition qu'ils concordent
c'est pas pareil en fait le truc c'est
que les pokémons ils sont plus dans une
forme de contrat social c'est-à-dire
qu'on l'ait nous
on s'occupe d'eux on les fait monter de
niveau mais en échange ba ils se battent
pour nous on peut les utiliser et c'est
le truc c'est que l'asservissement bas
ça jamais vraiment marché
il a toujours eu soin d échec soit des
abolitions et la domestication la vraie
domestication ben c'est pas quelque
chose qui se perd en une génération
or il ya bien des pokémon qui sont
domestiqués donc habitués à l'homme avec
un contrôle de la reproduction etc
mais ceux des domestiques comme ils
veulent en une génération tarde t il
sont capturées servile et c et d qui
sont libérés ils vivront dans la nature
il se débrouille comme des chefs comme
par exemple le gang des cars à puce
ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure donc
on peut pas vraiment parler de
domestication non plus et puis en plus
il ya des pokémon qui font absolument
parce que le dresseur demande genre
pikachu ne veux pas rentrer dans une
pokéball et les pokémon ont déjà tué des
hommes
c'est ce qu'on apprend dans l'ue cariou
et les mystères de mieux que je n'ai pas
vu ils disent que dans les anciens temps
il y avait des guerres et que les gens
utilisent et des pokemon
je parle de vraie guerre parfum de tour
mois molière avec potentiellement des
morts humain donc c'est très difficile
de faire rentrer les pokémon dans une
case tu vois pas ce que ils sont ni
esclave ni domestiquer ceni des animaux
pour l'homme en fait ils ont un statut
totalement inédit et c'est ça qui rend
le monde des pokémon si intéressant quoi
aucune âme c'est très difficile quand on
creuse un petit peu le sujet vous
trouvez une preuve de l'intériorité du
statut des pokémon face à celui des
humains hormis le fait qu'on en ait créé
et c'est déjà pas mal
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne
rater aucun épisode et a lâché en
commentaire parce que vous vous avez
pensé tout ça parce que moi là c'est
juste un truc personnel sur un côté un
sujet de pokémon c'est hyper large on
aurait pu parler plein de choses et puis
il est fortement possible qu'il y ait
certains trucs que j'ai dit sur lesquels
vous soyez pas d'accord on se retrouve
dans deux semaines jeudi 18h vous envoie
du love et de la pisse